personally I think that there are easier
ways of telepathy
then using quantum entanglement already
we can take MRI scans EEG scans of the
brain decipher them using computers
shoot that information to another person
this is called radio enhanced telepathy
using quantum entanglement to do that
it's quite complicated because of the
problem of decoherence objects that
vibrate in phase when you separate them
are also coherent there's an umbilical
cord that emerges between two objects
that's called quantum entanglement
however we consist of trillions upon
trillions of atoms so to get to minds to
vibrate in unison like that would be
impossible the world's record for making
objects entangle there's only just a few
atoms imagine trying to entangle two
Minds together so it sounds like a neat
idea putting quantum entanglement with
telepathy but hey let's be real there's
an easier way to do it that's using
computers and radio